[Music]
junior year can hardly believe it we
need to talk about your sexual health no
no please no what you to be safe
dad why are you giving me these don't
forget to have fun that's why I have a
lot of rubbers for that specifically do
you think you should branch out make
some new friends
nope you never know what could happen
that's what I'm afraid of
[Music]
my letters are my most secret
possessions I write them when I have a
crush so intense I don't know what else
to do there are five total Peter
the most popular guy in school Kenny
from Camp Lucas from homecoming done
Ambrose from Model UN and Josh but he's
my sister's boyfriend what are you doing
nothing nobody else knows about them hey
can I talk to you I really appreciate it
but it's never gonna happen I'm sorry
what I think it's really cool that you
think I have cold inspects the letters
are out women tell me about it here's
the thing I had to make it look like I
liked you so somebody else would think I
like them what if we let people think
that we were actually together let's do
this
I've never seen you so happy did you
mean what you wrote in the letter I
lined to every single person in my life
justify yourself okay
[Music]
we can't just sit up in your room
writing love letters
you gotta tell people how you feel when
you feel it oh yeah you never saw me
[Music]